hey everybody it's Mike freder here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control cm.
l234 do5 Define document approve and
enforce physical and logical access
restrictions associated with changes to
organizational
[Music]
systems so hey if you're a def
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
of this cmmc defs and nist sp800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so uh in cmmc control cm.
l234 do5 Define document approve and
enforce physical and logical access
restrictions associated with changes to
organization ation systems I got to tell
you this is a big one and it's a control
thing that is going to take more than
just the IT department here because it's
talking about both physical and logical
security which means we've got to work
together baby yes it physical security
The Works we're all involved in this one
and lots of things uh assessors are
going to be looking for on this one so
let's get straight into it let's check
out the assessors are looking for on
this one and I think that's the fastest
way to know what will make them happy so
uh first assessment Point determined
physical access restrictions associated
with changes to the system are defined
so if we Define what physical access
restrictions exist now again we've got a
definition typically in our plan in the
beginning that talks about all of the
different elements of the physical uh
physical security system things like
door access swipes locking key cameras
you name it so again that shortens up
our answer and allows us to put a simple
answer that says physical access
restrictions are defined by the physical
premise security system and again we
should have a policy that says hey our
physical premise security system uh
contains these elements and that's how
we know that we are properly protecting
and can demonstrate that to an assessor
so again very key is to have a physical
security policy determined physical
access restrictions associated with
changes to the system are documented
physical premise security is documented
within the organization's physical
premise security system documentation
pretty simple and straightforward
determine if physical access
restrictions Associated uh with changes
to the system are approved now we start
getting into some more interesting
things physical access restrictions are
approved by the organization CIO who is
in charge of the building's physical
premise security so again now we're
naming someone who is ultimately in
charge of the building's physical
security very important we got to have
somebody who we can say is in charge of
this next determinate physical access
restrictions associated with changes to
the system are enforced the building's
physical premise security system is
enforced active and is tested daily by
all authorized users accessing the
physical premise of course right every
time you hit a door swipe that's a test
to see if it's going to work every time
you use a lock and key do we know if the
key works every time we show up on
camera the security camera the entrances
exits in security sensitive areas well
do the cameras pick us up and so that's
a daily test of the system next
determine if logical access restrictions
associate with changes to the system are
defined now be careful we're switching
from physical to logical here all of a
sudden you're going from physical
premise security to it security so again
logical access restrictions are defined
within the firewall Network
infrastructure system permissions Active
Directory Group Policy and individual
system access so again uh you know with
this we're definitely kind of moving the
needle from physical into more of an IT
world next assessment point I know this
is a big control you guys lots of
assessment points determine if logical
access restrictions associated with
changes to the system are documented uh
logical access restrictions are
documented within configuration
baselines and network documentation next
determine if logical access restrictions
associated with changes to the system
are approved logical uh access
restrictions associated with the system
changes are approved via the it ticking
system finally determine if logical
access restrictions associated with the
changes to the system are enforced aha
are they actually enabled and working
enforcement of logical access
restrictions associated with changes to
the system are executed as a part of the
it ticketing resolution process and
tested by authorized users to ensure
they get the intended result in
coordination with the IT team now I
don't know about you but that's a whole
lot of assessment points and a whole lot
of information to cover and everybody's
going to be a little bit different on
this one and it's always tough when
you've got to really have multiple
members of your team working together to
come up with the answer to a single
control so hey at on call the good news
is we can help we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
the DARS nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a a proper on call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc compliance.com or check out the bio
below to for links to help get help
right now love the content we're putting
out here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button really
means the world to us when you do that
and smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance ners roll it out until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you next
[Music]
time